that shot is incredible you can't do
fire like that as visual effects back
then there was not the technology for it
what
what's it going to take
whoa
hold the phone the kid was 100 cg
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we're still practicing social distancing
and i also just realized i can utilize
the entire length of this couch we got
some dragons and fire we got some old
school vfx i've got my smiles and my
frowns and my raised eyebrows i got a
new one check this one out
okay so reign of fire i haven't seen
this movie in forever but i remember
loving it what a cool movie it's the
dragon apocalypse they dig deep enough
and they find a bunch of dragons and the
dragons take over the world
everything you want to see in a movie
this movie has it brutal
post-apocalyptic soldiers dragons
we're about to see this shot a shot
that's so good it's stuck with me for
life
dude look at that fire
look at how that fire is not interacting
with the wind from the dragon at all
come on come now wren
that shot is incredible you can't do
fire like that as visual effects back
then there was not the technology for it
and like the lighting on the dragon was
super good dude watch watch all the
people get engulfed by the flame at the
bottom how do you guys think they did
this convoy shot so it definitely looks
like that fire is actually there for
real like you're getting proper
occlusion of the foreground elements as
they get engulfed by fire like there's a
really good depth mat going on with cg
fire but this is obviously real looking
at the scale of the fire i would say
that's miniatures i think you're right
so are we talking about like a robot
controlled flame thrower i think they
probably just flamed this shot for real
and they just replaced whatever
whatever's holding the flamethrower with
a dragon like the dragon's coming at the
end of this whole process so you're
talking about a man in green pajamas not
necessarily not necessarily i got some
research so first and foremost the fire
is real but they actually have a
caterpillar not the bug but like one of
the things that scoops like a backhoe on
the end of it is a giant propane
flamethrower okay okay it shoots liquid
propane so they're just taking that
they're going
to just you know lighten up that set
that means that the scale has to be at
the scale of a freaking tractor like a
one to two scale kind of situation you
can freeze frame this shot and if you
line up what an excavator looks like and
about how high it can raise its front
arm you would probably imagine then that
this couch is probably how big those
cars are in the shot and and that's why
like the fire looks so good is because
they're matching the scale of the shot
really really well obviously doing it
one to one would be like do they even
make flame throwers this big oh yeah
they did a bunch of one-to-one shots
they went through eight tons of liquid
propane in this movie eight tons so i
mean imagine you write out your movie
budget and you submit it and you're like
we're gonna need funds for about eight
tons of liquid propane and then the
executives are like this would be this
would be a good movie
i distinctly remember this movie having
some really cool animation on the
dragons too like oh man this dragon
means business and this came before the
dragons in harry potter but they
specifically inspired the dragons from
harry potter there's actually some
really cool things that came into play
when they were trying to create the
dragon so they first started like a
komodo dragon you know the real thing
like a lizard style dragon um they're
like just doesn't look mean enough and
what they did is they went back and
remodeled it so like the body was kind
of hung below the wings like a wasp
they also put all like all the holes in
the wings so you can like see those
tatters and those tears and see the
spikes because that all makes it look
more mean and rugged it's all about the
silhouette and once again like these cg
dragons look really good because they're
almost always in silhouette or lit with
like very specific directional scene
lighting
wait what
that's the jurassic park reference horn
i'm referencing the jurassic park t-rex
because they were smart and they lit the
scene in a way that didn't require them
to use really fancy physically based
rendering that jurassic park horn i'm
glad we honked it because there's a
couple shots here that i think are
really good examples of it this is a
really good example having objects that
can include it we have all the
atmosphere in the scene as well dude
that shot through the grate there so
it's obscured that's nice yeah a simple
technique to really make the dragons
feel larger is simply have it break
frames that was something they did all
the time for game of thrones you can
never really see the entirety of a
dragon the wings were usually clipping
the tops or sides of the framing and
that just kind of gives a sense of like
wow this is so big the camera can't even
capture it all like this was like the
first time we saw legit dragons in
movies i mean we obviously had dragon
heart before that but you know that
wasn't like a badass dragon these are
badass dragons i want to watch this
movie again i do too please leave a
comment suggesting some other visual
effects that we should look at there's
nothing else for us to react to and we
need your help what time is it
are either of you guys basketball fans
and have been watching the new last
dance michael jordan documentary halfway
through every episode they have like
commercials that are really funny
because they're like we're a mid 90s
news broadcast but we're talking about
the future this is the kind of stuff
that espn will eventually make a
documentary about they'll call it
something like the last dance it's gonna
be lit you don't even know what that
means yet i didn't notice any visual
effects were being done until the final
commercial that's another documentary
for another day you're starting to sound
like kenny mayne and this is starting to
sound like a state farm commercial but i
was watching i was like what's wrong
with his lips what is going on here this
is an effect i didn't anticipate what i
initially thought was them setting up
old cameras and trying to mimic the old
broadcast style no these were actually
originally broadcast back in the 90s
those are real sports news anchors but
they're making them say other things so
when i looked into it the articles that
have already been written about this
they say they did it with deep fakes the
problem is that no one really knows what
that means i know what you know what it
means just doing vfx's his face isn't a
deep fake replacing the mouth isn't a
deep fake a defect is when that computer
can basically repaint a face by hand
using its knowledge of you know what
thousands and thousands of pictures of
that face looks like so the whole face
is an ai reconstruction it uses deep
learning that's why it's called a deep
fake
like just manipulating or re-morphing or
retargeting a face that's not a deep
fake i don't think there's any machine
learning involved in these shots
i think they are filming a mouth and
they are trying to match up the cadence
and the rhythm of the words to the chin
movements of the news anchor and they're
just replacing his mouth with new lips
so you watch closely sometimes lips
slide up and down in the face and the
cheeks here don't react there is nothing
happening in the cheeks that match the
lips you can kind of see almost like a
soft feathered mask around the lips they
kind of float there in that face and
that soft feathered mask but the part
where she smiles where she turns and
looks at the other news anchor at the
end and smiles that's going from the
composite footage to the real footage
when she turns her head there
and it stays real for the rest of that
moment here comes so that's fake and
then boom that's real okay yeah also
kind of notice how the dude's lips and
like immediately around his lips are
very clear the clarity is high and it
doesn't match the graininess of the rest
of his head and you know they could have
deep faked the entire face then just cut
out the mouth and stuck the mouth back
on too that is a possibility i mean that
was what i initially thought
specifically because they were saying
they did a deep fake so i was going in
under the assumption that they actually
did do some sort of deep fake you are
the deep fake expert here and you're
saying it's not a deep fake the reason i
don't think they did a deep fake and
then cut the lips and stuck the lips
back in is because of the teeth the
teeth look pretty good in fact they look
very clear and yeah you can have clear
teeth in a deep fake but it's just
something about the the clarity and the
way the lips move across them it doesn't
look like a defect to me remember when
you gave tupac a center tooth yeah and
call them toothpucks
so now we are looking at terminator dark
fate and it's the newest minotaur movie
there's some crazy effects throughout
this whole thing in fact there's like
there's almost too many effects to talk
about so we're just going to look at the
two main monitors that are in the scene
here
i use that
that's cool
what does [ __ ]
the reason why i love that shot right
there is because they had the gun there
the whole time but the bag was fake your
brain doesn't have a chance to realize
the bag isn't real before it starts
getting all amorphous and obviously fake
but that feels like a shot that was
designed by a visual effects artist as
opposed to a director without any
experience with visual effects that guy
forgot to take his green screen suit off
in the background oh wait you're going
to give him terminator arms later
dude for a moment there i thought that
was legit a mistake
look at those beautiful hits
god the cg in this movie is nuts i
really like tim miller's work just
because his understanding of like
spectacle and visuals is so on point
after doing all those videos with blur
studio that's right yeah tim miller like
he pioneered that crazy cinematic look
that video games back in the day had and
he turned into an actual movie director
he directed deadpool they had a tiny
budget but his knowledge of visual
effects was so deep that they were able
to stretch all of that budget out and
make a full-length deadpool movie with
tons of effects everywhere
they're very very ballsy with their uh
digital doubles in this now there's like
straight up there's one right there yeah
there's a lot of digital doubles going
on here sometimes they look great and
sometimes it comes out of that physics
thing we need them to move in a way that
things don't quite move and like it
stands out a little bit
but like that look like with the leg
break there looks great like from a
rendering point of view the lighting's
perfect the cloth looks great but like
the part where he jumps up to like the
scaffolding like he jumps a little fast
a little weird where things can't quite
accelerate like that it looks weird
because we are not used to seeing real
superpowers how do you move that fast it
kind of looks wrong but it's because
we've never seen anyone jump 30 feet
like that before yeah i think a good
example is like the boston dynamics
demos when you see the mechanics
required to operate a body of a certain
weight you see the impact and strength
that's required if a guy was like
hopping around on these beams of giant
robot he's probably gonna be knocking it
over bending and breaking this stuff as
he's connecting with it yeah that's
obviously a ton of work and also i don't
think people really care you know if you
sat down you're like all right we're
gonna make the physics perfect i don't
think the audiences would really care
they're watching robots fight like the
point i'm trying to make is that's it's
always been the case in movies that
physics get violated okay sure
oh man this is what i want to see i was
just like oh god i love the feral fluid
effect look at that
yeah
see that kick there where she went into
that that cabinet like that looked good
in my opinion that had the right kind of
speed and momentum
the head bonks oh that is brutal so this
is the thing where they actually did
several different takes one with the
real actor like when she's like slamming
the thing into his head she's actually
hitting a pad that's on the ground so
she's able to give all of her force into
the the actual motion of it and then
they filmed a separate plate with her
knot in it of him just kind of reacting
and then they add all the visual effects
with the digi double and then composite
it all together i i feel like they do a
pretty good job of like selling the kind
of power someone with an incredible
amount of strength has when fighting
another person with an incredible amount
of strength
that future never happened
because i stopped it i don't even think
it's de-aging man it's just i'm watching
this and i'm just like this is unreal
like look at that whoa we're looking at
sarah connor as she was in terminator 2.
we're looking at john connor as he was
in terminator 2. they even got like the
perfect like 90s sunglasses for arnold
it's by far the hardest work we've done
on wow humans whoa
hold the phone the kid was 100 cg
okay there is a real person there with
the headband needed a full body track
and a clothing track for some reason i
think they were just like we want the
option to do full cg in case something
goes crazy yeah so his hair is cg there
you know it seems like an easy thing oh
keep the hair for real and then just
replace the face but how like the the
hair is leaving a shadow on the face how
it interacts with the face sometimes
it's easier just to make the hair cg as
well i'll say it's nice watching a vfx
shot like this that just works that
completely surpasses the uncanny valley
for me yeah this is perfect it's on the
other like nothing about that is
triggering my evolutionary senses of
like that's not a human also i love the
casting of the arnold body double
because he looks exactly like arnold
hold on we
just found our next piece of merchandise
freaking chin strap skull cap motion
tracking corridor hats
if you want to get the latest in street
wear you should wear one of those
my strength alone can't do it all right
is there anything you can do to help
last clip guys it's one shot it's one
shot from the old do not miss your
chance starring lou ferrigno those pecs
could gouge your eyes out but i don't
know what this effect is yet i don't
even know what you're trying to show us
here
optical printing effects right there
light effects yeah here we go do that
rainbow square
he's going big using magic to make him
giant
yeah
no green screens here this is
he's just growing giant
wait i know it i know what's going on i
know it's going to i hope
i got it the camera's just moving closer
yeah
yeah
but here's the thing that's how it would
actually physically work if you were to
suddenly get large you're now looking up
at the thing which is the same exact
perspective shift as pushing the camera
into that person so it's pretty obvious
how they did this the camera's just
moving closer to him on the beach so it
looks like he's getting bigger but it's
a separate shot well the foreground
there is probably just a single picture
that's been stuck over the frame and you
can tell because she's not moving at all
the woman casting the spell and they
cover that up with a magic square
rainbow so you can't tell she's moving
then it helps sell the scale and then
beyond that little still frame of the
foreground is just a camera pushing in
towards hercules because it gets bigger
the number of people watching this video
right now that are not subscribed are
literally half
what
every week we say subscribe no one
subscribes every week we politely ask
subscribe we know how many of you are
not subscribed we know these things and
yet you continue to ignore us what's the
point i don't even know what i'm doing
anymore you know don't subscribe fine
delete the youtube app off your phone
don't ever watch this video
i'm just just
you're free to do
as your as you please just
go and live your life be free
i don't know just go
i don't know just
if you're not going to subscribe just
just do whatever you're gonna do get it
over with
i'm just they're not guys they're not
subscribing what's it gonna take what's
it going to take how many dolls are
gonna have to ring
this is it this is the last time i ever
asked you to say subscribe unless this
changes
this might be okay sam this is the last
subscribing push
i'm going to do until things change
and i'm i'm not the one who has to
change it's you